- I feel like a badass bitch
when I wear my hijab. (laughs)
(upbeat music)
- Hijab is not just a piece of cloth
that we put on our head.
- It's a symbol, to me, about being seen
for your intelligence, before your beauty.
- Wearing the hijab has
made me unapologetic
about who I am, as a person.
- When I started wearing
hijab, I was scared
of like, "What's this person gonna say?"
I went through 21 years of not wearing it.
- Once I came to that realization,
that I think that wearing the hijab will
make me a better person,
and hopefully help me
become the kind of person
I want to be in the future.
That's when I was like,
"Nope, I need to do this."
So I went in, the first
day of sophomore year
of high school, with, I remember,
it was like a bright pink hijab. (laughs)
- I was actually
encouraged by other people,
and relatives, to take
it off, and not wear it.
So, it was my choice to put it on,
and it was my decision to
practice this part of my faith.
- Well, my mother was very much against me
wearing the hijab, because
my parents are both Muslim,
but they're from Iran, and
over there, wearing the hijab
is something that is
enforced among everybody.
It is a political tool.
Well, I put my religious
beliefs out there,
and possibly be harmed.
- It's unfortunate, that people have
this negative opinion about the hijab.
People who think that the
hijab oppresses women,
but I hope to be an example,
that I'm not an oppressed
woman who wears the hijab.
- I had to keep explaining
that this is not about
trying to prove what a good Muslim I am.
Whether you wear hijab or
not is between you and God,
it is no one's place to judge.
I don't care if you're
a stripper at night,
and you wear hijab during the day.
That is your business, you wear
hijab on your terms, honey,
and that's what I do.
- When I go up on stage at
open mics, and I perform,
I definitely shock people
because I'm the only one
wearing hijab, that gets up
on these public open mics.
And they have the stereotypical
thing, when I walk in,
like, "Oh, what is that
person doing here?"
And then, all of a sudden,
I'm up there on stage,
and I'm performing about a breakup,
or a relationship, or death, or divorce,
or things like that, and people
are like, "Oh, she's human."
It's like, "Surprise! We are."
- I have changed the way I
look, to represent who I am.
And because my identity is so out there,
and I have to embrace it,
and I have to embrace that,
yes, sometimes, I'm going to
be looked at and get questions.
You have no choice but to
become more confident about it,
because you are wearing your
identity on your sleeve.
- I do identify myself as a
feminist, and so I do write
a lot about social issues,
and cultural issues,
that transcend all these barriers.
And the fact that I'm speaking
up about these things,
in a hijab, it breaks
that stereotype, too,
that we're the introverted,
domesticated, submissive
kind of women, when, no.
We have a lot of outspoken,
very strong independent females,
who do practice this part of the faith.
- It's awesome that earlier
this year, Ibtihaj Muhammad
went to the Olympics, wearing
the hijab, as a fencer there,
representing the US team.
And it just goes to show,
again, that she wasn't there
because she wore her hijab.
She was there because she
is good at what she does.
- And honestly, whenever I
see any Muslim woman in hijab
doing amazing things, making
it to magazine covers,
and succeeding in different
elements of cooking,
or baking, or fashion,
or business, in finance,
it's a huge empowering feeling.
It's an inspiration, you
see it, and you feel like,
"Yeah, someone else
could do it, so can I."
So I'm going to keep doing what I do,
practicing my faith the way that I am.
- I see women sexualized to the core,
I see women having to feel
validation from how they look,
and I have struggled through
trying to seek that validation
through how I look, as well.
And to cover my hair, and
to have everything covered,
to me, is a symbol of, "I
want nothing to do with that,
"for myself, and I am
taking my beauty back."
- With the rise of social
media, you see that
there's not just one way for a woman
who wears hijab to look.
You can have so many different styles.
- Having that opportunity to
do fun stuff with our hijabs
is really nice, to be able to add colors,
and add sparkles, and
wrap it certain ways,
so that we get to express
our feelings of beauty,
in a certain way, as well.
(happy music)